[Music]
I have been since a couple of years very
much concerned with the state of our
planet and with the crisis that has been
captured by the term of the anthropocene
[Music]
my name is Jurgen Ren I'm director at
the Max Planck Institute for the history
of science here in Berlin and since a
couple of months I'm also a director at
the newly founded Max Planck Institute
for geoanthropology Indiana
the anthropocene is the proposed new
Epoch on of Earth history and the term
has been proposed by Paul cotson Nobel
Prize winner in chemistry director at
the Max Planck Institute for chemistry
in Mainz in the year 2000 the
anthropocene itself is a concept that
reaches much Beyond geology
it's the time of the human impact so
naturally you need many disciplines to
actually deal with this concept
humans are transforming geological time
into historical time by making use of of
fossil fuels for instance on the other
hand they have become themselves a
geological Force they have changed the
climate in a most dramatic way with
probably no analog in Earth history the
date that is proposed now for the
beginning of the anthropocene from the
stratigraphic point of view is just
after the first world war synchronous
was the first atomic explosion because
they live you know a radioactive
sediment all over the world
science is very good at drilling deep
holes and you know looking from a
specialized angle at problems and
understanding the mechanisms but the
anthropocene is a concept that requires
a different thinking and I think artists
are sometimes very good in capturing
sort of this holistic perspective
this is an interaction between science
and and art that you know requires from
the scientists an even more active you
know transgression of their laboratory
work into you know an exhibition that is
understandable to the public so let's
see what we can discover here
it is the research that actually Roots
the anthropocene in the sedimentary
record this is a peat core
and it shows clearly uh
signals of the nuclear weapon test so
you can really see some of the major
events marking the anthropocene you know
in those core elements
microplastics as you find it in river or
lake sediments are of course clearly a
product of of human activity and there
was one surprise in which this
microplastic was found in a layer I
think from the beginning of the 19th
century so people didn't yet produce
plastic but the micro the microplastic
is so
has such a tendency to spread that it
even spoils the sedimentary record and
goes into deeper layers you know which
of course obfuscates the the record but
it's still a sign of the profoundness
and of the uh the global impact that it
has
foreign
[Music]
we have quite a number of social
political activists so it's not just a
knowledge which comes from Academia and
it's being translated so to say in the
political field or in the social field
the point which became very relevant in
our Mississippi project was to see that
on the one side the anthropocene is a
planetary process on the other side it
articulates itself in very specific
historical contexts and one has to have
developed a sensibility to to deal with
the anthropocynical
repercussions in these kind of concrete
social contexts we were interacting with
local activists and not just of course
you know bringing them some academic
insights but learning from them about
sort of the local consequences and the
local actions they are taking so the
anthropocene discourse is really about
knowledge in action
foreign
[Music]
so when people ask about which direction
which overall direction we have to take
in order to cope with the challenges of
the anthropocene
there are basically two answers one is
Back To Nature and the other answer is a
modernist answer let's you know govern
nature even more let's promote
technologies that you know increase the
control of humanity over nature
I personally think both will not work
because we have so deeply interfered
with the planetary system that's the
meaning of the anthropocene that there
is no way back to Nature if we continue
to interfere in the way we have done so
in the past
this will lead to collapse we have to
stop for sure the use of fossil fuels so
we have to rethink our entire Energy
System and not just naturally but on a
global level
it's very important that scientists from
all over the world meet and discuss
these problems and they should do it in
an open way interacting also with a
larger public so I think the Berlin
science week is a great event in which
science is again center stage in a way
but has also to confront its
responsibility for dealing with the
challenges of this world it needs to be
abroad a global and a public discussion
so I very much cherished these events
even though you know they require a lot
of traveling which is you know
increasing our carbon footprint but some
of these discussions actually need
personal encounters in particular for
the younger people they need to have the
opportunity to network to meet people
from other parts of the world and talk
about not just their Specialties but the
kind of global problems that are
connected to the anthropocene
we know enough to act I mean there's no
reason that we have to wait for further
knowledge about you know climate change
to act upon it you know it's absolutely
necessary to act quickly and to act
thoroughly and with to concentrate all
our energies to prevent uh you know this
Global Climate crisis
[Music]